[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
what's going on guys I hope you guys can
hear me fine man I hope you guys can
hear me fine
I don't know I don't know man I don't
know sometimes these things are weird
man sometimes things don't appear the
way they should be
can you guys hear me fine
am I being heard
they changed so much stuff
can you guys hear me fine
hold on let me see what I sound like I
can't sound like ridiculous man
sometimes you guys don't know what a
good mic sounds like
why can't
bear with me man
I'm going
to the to the Stream
all right all right so I sound good man
I sound good everything is good crisis
averted
all right man so this is what's gonna
happen all right
not done talking about games this week
with this this this fine what is today
today's a Friday this fine Friday what's
going on mccam I want to talk more about
games but I kind of want to play games
too so I think we're going to mix them
because uh stuff's been going on people
have been going crazy so I want to mix
them I want to talk about games while we
play games and I got a fun game that
that I got going on here man uh because
I do feel like a lot of you you know you
want to talk about the topics that's all
you really care about so there's the
topics of the stream we're going to talk
about all that if you want to add
something if I get to it in the chat
that's fine you know if you super chat
it yeah that would definitely get my
attention more but
here's what we're going to play David
Rodriguez asked what have you played
Vanguard that's that's a negative that
is definitely I have not played Vanguard
I don't really mess with Call of Duty
games like that if that makes sense to
you I don't I don't particularly like
them too much they're not they're not my
cup of tea you know I honestly feel like
they're they've never been my cup of tea
but they're definitely not my cup of tea
so first thing I do want to talk about
is I want to talk about
the Sega deal that's going on but we're
going to go ahead and uh move over to
the game here in a couple minutes uh you
know first off how's everyone doing man
put in that chat how is everyone doing
are you guys are you guys breathing good
man is everything fine uh because uh I'm
in a good mood I'm in a relatively good
mood I don't know why I'm gonna try to
move my mic without it falling off the
desk so you know wish me luck
okay okay I moved it very lightly so it
didn't fall off the desk so I think we
good I think we good
are you the guy who caught EDP I have no
clue what that is
I feel like you might be a troll I don't
know but
I feel like you might be a troll just a
little bit feel like you might be in
trouble Halo infinite 343 just said oh
that that's interesting that's
interesting all right so uh
I have been playing this game here
recently so we're gonna go and move over
to the next scene
uh as you guys could see I've been
playing me a little bit of writer's
Republic
I don't know how you guys feel about
Ryan's Republic if you've even been told
about anything try to kept catch up on
topics
what's going on with the topics man
I'm kind of curious on us am I missing
anything
I'm kind of I'm kind of curious if I'm
missing anything guys like uh besides
the Halo thing I didn't hear about the
Halo thing
[Applause]
oh
um
it's called writer's Republic guys it's
called writer's Republic
you know I I feel like we need to do a
little bit more you know we can still
talk about the about the nice topics but
I think we need to we need to play games
a little bit more what do you guys think
man what do you guys think I think we
need to play games a little bit more
obviously I'm losing this race like
crazy but that that's part of uh part of
the world man learning how to play these
games
and we good we're good
so what do you guys want to talk about
first what what topic on on the board do
you guys want to talk about first
very curious man I don't really care
what we talk about first but I'm curious
what you guys want to talk about first
because at the end of the day it is
about you guys
I'm curious what you guys the forza I do
got fours on my Xbox
you know maybe after a couple minutes of
playing this we could jump into some
Forza I don't know if you guys are you
guys been feeling Forza
man you guys really want to talk about
Forza
see it's hold up hold up hold up I'm
pretty sure you guys could see this give
me a second man there's fours are right
there that 101 gigs
I mean I've always thought they've had
decent games from the start so like
close to the sun it's never been one of
those things where I've never felt like
they didn't have a good game
hold up someone said
I will read that here in a second
PlayStation PS sales
does anyone got a link to that because I
know that they were like all in the
millions like there weren't anything
crazy
does anyone got a link to those cells
I mean I could Google them
I could definitely Google them that's
nothing not to get a hold of
what's up Mr glass
what's up uh
Daniel Hill oh
that would have been
very unfortunate if I would have hit
that that uh that Hill
look at this Canyon this place looks
really nice
oh
look man it's I'm making it look easy
this is the tutorial I need a I need to
cool my rocks man's tutorial are you
playing on the Xbox or PC it's the Xbox
obviously you know I play it on this
Xbox man I don't be doing that PC stuff
like that I do have some games of going
to stream for PC but not right now I
won't be streaming those games right now
[Music]
you guys know it man snow tricks
there's a panda
so it looks like you can do a backup
oh
one more
oh that was that was very clear and
smooth
I wonder if these are real people
I appreciate the kind words you guys
really showed up for that review man I
really appreciate it I'm trying to get I
know that you know
I could do better on the review
structure I know I could and I'm
definitely going to improve on the
reviews you know who knows uh maybe I'll
be reviewing something in the future
you know we don't know what the future
holds it's been we don't know what the
future holds it
all right so let me go ahead
[Music]
all right so let's see what people be
talking about up here man
at work trying to catch the topics hey
yo Eddie how do you become a gaming
addict I play for an hour then fall off
I think I got attention to this order
look man it's just all about the game
some people really Vibe with other games
some people don't so I definitely
understand like that mindset like
sometimes
I'm bored
I try to do it all one second it's been
years competing at the highest level
what I discovered is that there's so
much more to the Republic than meets the
eye it's also about Adventure
exploration and connecting with the
outdoors all right a whole new level
what's going on anime what's going on
man anyway you need to hop on uh AGS
podcast
uh look nothing against those guys over
there man but you know I'm trying to I'm
just trying to stay away from the from
the bad vibes these days you know
duplicate I got I gotta I gotta be
better on that stuff I got to be better
overall I gotta work on my my
the way I handle situations I gotta make
sure that I'm just a better person in
general and sometimes I be letting the
you know the that stuff get to me I'll
be letting this stuff get up me upset
and you know I gotta do better on that
up with friends other writers and
compete against each other I feel like I
feel like the camera
could be a little bit better I'm
skipping the cinematics
I forgot to mention skipping the somatic
oh there's no beef it's just I I'm
trying to stay away from you know that
type of drama it's not even that they do
a drama podcast they don't I'm just
trying to stay away from you know any
type of podcast that could put me in a
bad a bad mindset and you know sometimes
you know stuff I like to stay away from
heated stuff you guys know what I'm
saying like I just I need to be in a
better place mentally and you know
because the thing is is like nothing
against their content but I know me I'll
get two two passionate about subject and
too aggressive okay and then I'll end up
just going on this going on the end man
and I need to stay away from that I need
to not put myself in situations that put
that me into that kind of situation the
potential to become champions
if that makes sense to you guys oh and
yeah he doesn't ride because you guys
know how uh some of these podcasts roll
man like this way of looking at you know
it can get pretty heated that's why I
try to stay out of these spaces these
spaces gotten pretty uh intense here
recently
I hope that you guys understand I don't
even know what I'm doing this is the
song everything you do you do count I
feel you negative can breathe negativity
it's not even that they have like a
negative brand it's just you know
I just can't like because it's just one
of those podcasts where it's like you
know it can get real toxic really fast
and I'm just trying to stay away from
that in general
[Applause]
you know ever since I like stopped
entertaining all the Contour stuff and
I've been trying to just be a better
person in general I've definitely been
in a better place mentally uh Nano
designer said yo Addie how do you feel
about that Halo pass they showed I'm so
happy to see flaming helmet back I saw
the flaming helmet thing how you guys
feel about that we might actually bring
that up
and actually really talk about that
because I like what I saw I definitely
liked what I saw
our kid
oh
big this map is just don't crash like
thunder
all right so
but I I think you guys get what I'm
talking about though like you know
that I I love Halo man I really love
Halo and I want Halo to be in a good
spot I really do
all I had to feedback with no games that
they had God of War Horizon they
shouldn't be uh be loud right now I
don't know what you mean by that Daniel
even mama
[Music]
oh backtrack
so I mean first thing we could talk
about probably I think the best thing to
talk about is the Sega deal how you guys
feel about Sega in Microsoft joining
forces do you think that that's a
possibility I'm kind of curious if they
joined forces to what degree will they
join forces is it going to be one of
those things where it's just going to be
a couple things but nothing serious I'm
kind of curious what you guys have to
say about that and whether or not it's
going to be something big or something
small I know people feel like you know
this doesn't mean nothing and to a point
I'm going to entertain that where it's
nothing serious but I don't think it's
to the point where people are acting
like it's the Sony thing because uh I
don't think it's I don't think it's the
Sony thing
oh God
hold up hold up we got to do the tricks
man
even though we trying to win we still
gotta do oh
that dude wrecked causing me to wreck
oh I haven't uh I might get to Forza
later
I want to play a little bit of this
because I actually really enjoyed what I
played on it
man you guys oh my gosh you guys really
gonna come at me over the night mode
can I have my Xbox whatever mode I
decide
does it gotta be oh oh
I feel like I should be able to have my
Xbox in whatever mode I desire
you guys are gonna bowl with me and make
it into night mode is that what's going
on here
oh I'm about to I'm I'm done I'm done
yep
[Applause]
oh yeah that's right
yeah if you guys don't need to hear that
anyway
hopefully uh it's probably gonna get
claimed but at this point man I'm so
used to the industry claiming just basic
music that's in games like they really
need to fix that like
I understand why they don't fix stuff to
a point but part of me feels like the
industry needs to be better on that in
general uh why isn't your oh yeah that's
right you're shaming me man you're
shaming me for my Xbox stuff
uh I'm not sure it's super serious
either it's bigger than the Sony though
because Sarah ball uh Sarah bond is
involved I do think that that has some
relevancy but I don't know exactly what
it indicates that she's talking about is
she's talking about because she's like
actually doing stuff with it or she
talking about because it's something
that is important to her the second
important to her is this deal because
she's doing something important I think
right now we don't know what's happening
with that so so by slaying that first
event you know if you guys get what I'm
saying
[Music]
hey look at my face I'm totally stoked
oh and your first big event is just
around the corner so mix it up and lay
it down because that's gonna be extreme
peace
before Red Bull holy bike your first
Biggie put your new bike to use at this
next Super gnarly race it's gonna demand
Speed and Performance remember use the
old Waypoint tool to Transit all right
there we go sorry about that Sega is
planning a comeback uh did you see the
announcement the Warhammer 3 for Game
Pass day one yeah and actually I really
enjoy that I think I might actually play
that game just because of that
announcement
I've actually a really big fan of
of those type of games like that I've
never played a Warhammer game
but I'm curious exactly you know what
I'd get myself into and since it since
it would be in Game Pass day one I would
be more interested in trying if that
makes sense to you guys
I just feel like as long I feel like
this could lead to games like
like Persona 6 coming to Game Pass not
game pass but just coming to the Xbox in
general I mean who knows maybe it can
lead to games like Persona 6 coming to
Game Pass
you know it would be it would be crazy
if they announced that they got Game
Pass like imagine the crazy announcement
Pass and it's in their day one
I think that would be very big
I'm willing to try it though like if
they're willing to give me uh to let me
try that game for just a subscription
service that I'm already subbed to
because of uh Xbox I'm willing to to
give that a try all right so let's
I'll get back to the chat here in a
second man we gotta beat them this time
man last time we got second I refused to
come to second to anyone
oh man they look how big these people
are on these bikes
sprints
I'm in second place right now
oh first place
I don't even know what uh it kind of
reminds me of Forza a little bit like
with the progressive system
if you guys get that
four is that this is not Forza Horizon
guys why do you guys think it's Forza
I mean do do I have it in the in the
description that I'm playing Forza I did
say I was gonna play Forza today on
Twitter but I'm not playing yet
you know at least I'm kind of winning in
this like once once we get on Forza oh
God it's gonna be a completely different
oh I'm dead
ow and look how crazy it looks when you
hit stuff
I I felt my own bones breaking
hold up
I got this i got this
this game's pretty beautiful
it's pretty beautiful man I can say I
will try it
you guys came in here to see me
get elves on Forza didn't you
you guys are very cruel
I don't like that kind of mindset you
guys have right now
let's just chill and and wait till
addict messes up in Forza
you guys want to see me losing Forza
see first place that's how you do it
first place
how the trees graphics and foot oh oh uh
like I don't know are you referring to
uh a certain incident that happened on
uh
on I IOP is that what you're referring
to
you know let me go back into this game
and see if the trees are blowing
so give me a couple minutes let's see
look at that hold up holy [__] hold up
hold up
hold up hold up
see the trees are totally moving
look at this the trees are definitely
moving guys
the trees are definitely moving
they're moving
see I think you can get off my back
I will admit they're not moving as much
as they should be moving for AAA title
but you know we ain't going to talk
about that they move it and that's all
that matters
now I have a feeling you guys gonna come
in here into the IOP with that smoke
Sunday
you guys are gonna really come at me
Sunday aren't you
a big embossed event I don't know what a
boss event is
how does the stream look guys does the
stream look clean or is something still
like or something look off on the Stream
I'm kind of curious how the stream looks
writer's Republic five no this isn't
writers Republic
next 240p come on next stop being mean
take off with questions finish with
answers
Red Bull so I'm curious to hear you guys
opinion on the Sega thing well I do this
next race I want you guys to put in the
chat
how you feel the second thing is going
to work I know we've talked about
possibilities what do you feel like can
establish with this Sega partnership do
you think that it could be anything
remote or do you think that you know for
the most part it's just going to be a
little bit of a little bit of marketing
and maybe you know some some back-end
deals but definitely put in there uh
once I finish this race I'm gonna go
over these responses man we go to see
exactly what what kind of crazy
outlayish stuff you guys be thinking
this thing's gonna mean
man look at this
I'm about to lose
oh yo yo yo yo yo yo that is slippery
man it's slippery
I can't I can't press left trigger at
all
if I do it's a rat
oh God
yeah that that could have went better
that could have went better
look at all the snow on me
all right we're going we're going for uh
third hold up
okay okay okay here we go
third
we're going for second
can we get second
move out of my way
we got second
but the question that everyone has is
can we get first
probably not but we we're not in the
snow area anymore so he doesn't have
that advantage of me just sliding
everywhere
hold on I'm going for that first man
he's way up there
oh there he is he fell I don't know if
I'm playing against someone online or
not
hold up hold up no this is my
ah how'd that happen
no no no no no
oh God
that was a long drop
[Music]
oh my God
I thought it was over there guys Chad I
thought it was done
oh my God
oh he tripped he tripped
this is
this is a hard race it's very long we
got 10 left
thank you
there we go
it's looking like it's a wrap
we win it
doesn't matter if we wrecked man
I have to check this game out for
stadium this game has this game's on
stadia
man this game's pretty like responsive I
wouldn't play it on Stadium
[Applause]
look at that I won a big event already I
I I'm a God at writer public fan filthy
right at the Red Bull holy bike the
Revenge of Sega you guys really love
Sega like a lot of people really enjoy
all right the type of game Sega is and I
have to respect that first not a whole
lot but I do have to respect that I like
some of the game Sega has but I don't
know about like
them is is like a hole if that makes
sense to you guys
Sega is a free trial for all games
thank you
well that's crazy
I wonder what games is on Sega
I don't know I I kind of like the uh
xcloud I think xcloud actually works
pretty well I did play Destiny on statel
once uh that went pretty well
I have to say so myself
Crazy Taxi
we ain't really trying to mess with
Crazy Taxi too much
well man we might be going to uh Forza a
little sooner it looks like the the
servers crashed
well we'll play this Zen moment thing a
little bit to show you guys the stuff
that I actually like doing on this game
we don't have to play the the single
player
bring back Shinobi that's Cognito stuff
man it's not really my stuff like it
Shinobi really like that it's snow if
you like that
because I don't know what kind of game
Shinobi is
foreign
equip gear
it used to it used to let you change
equipment
probably have to get away from whatever
Camp we're at
whoa
foreign
I don't know why it's not letting me
choose
it should let me choose
there was a way to like manually yeah
helicopter drop let's go up down with
the helicopter
so that button does that
I don't know man
I don't know if I can get down on the
Shinobi thing
they would have to re-bring it back if
that makes sense to you guys they'd have
to re-bring it back like up to date for
me to really try that game out
I'm not saying that I wouldn't ever try
it they just have to Rebrand it back a
new Sonic Adventure game you know I
actually really enjoy Sonic Adventure
too
and let me turn take this hoodie off
I'm burning up a little bit
just a little bit
I would play Shinobi if they brought it
back in some in some form
I would definitely play it
if they brought it back I don't want to
play the new one uh the old ones though
like I know that
the Realms trying to get this patriarch
on tier where uh I had to play old games
but I feel like if we did the patreon
tier you guys are just gonna troll me
and like do I really want to set myself
up for that to be trolled
oh God
foreign
here we go oh
yeah I'm getting a little bit nervous
for this game
come on
you guys troll me just in the regular
chat I can't imagine if I gave you true
trolling power
like you guys would never let me outlive
that
the biggest thing I want from the Sega
thing is I just want persona 5.
like can we please just get Persona 5 on
the platform please
like I I would appreciate some persona
5.
all right let me quit this session
because I feel like some of the the
options wasn't in that session
what what is some older games
realistically that you guys think I
should play that's not ridiculous like
let I want to emphasize that's not
ridiculous look at me chat not
ridiculous don't have me playing some
crazy stuff look at me chat not
ridiculous
because I feel like sometimes you guys
don't listen
I'll tell you not ridiculous and you'll
you'll Google the most ridiculous games
in the industry
and you know I can't give you guys that
power
great power comes great responsibility I
feel like some of you some of you would
be some Hancock if you got end up
getting like super human powers you know
the the uh what's it called uh Hancock
the with Will Smith like I feel like
that's what you guys are
you guys are going to end up like
abusing the powers
that's just my opinion
I feel like if you guys get some power
man it's gonna be a wrap some of you
abuse the chat man
have you put have you seen some of the
stuff that's super chatted on IOP some
of you already abused just a Super Chat
because it I mean look it does be funny
but you know regardless it's still a
little bit of abusing system just a
little bit yeah it's just a little bit
oh
my God
I don't understand like there was a way
that you could like change what kind of
vehicles and stuff that you have
but it doesn't look like they uh let you
do that right now
it doesn't look like it gives me the
option
I'm on
I'm on an island the biggest thing I
need to find out is how to change this
stuff man
I feel like
certain things have have messed up like
why hasn't it it popped up yet
why I'm at it let me
look at something real quick
all right so it looks like that's fine
for now
I'm gonna try it one more time
because I actually like this game but I
like the like the free roam like if
it'll let me do the stuff I was doing
earlier on the free roam chat it's
ridiculous like the free roam in this
game you could do some wild stuff
it's a regular stream kid
but see it's a regular stream but we
talking about stuff man
Halo raids what do you mean by Halo
raids
you might have to be a little bit more
specific on that I don't know what you
mean by Halo raids
feel free to uh to send an invite kit if
you're home we could jump on some uh on
some Forza Horizon or something because
it doesn't look like this game's working
the way it's supposed to
I can't remember what button I pushed
that's the back button
I feel like it was that button like when
you held it
Destiny like I don't think he knows
I don't know man we we about to jump off
uh this here in a second I'm gonna do
one what we're gonna do is because I I
like the game I just wanna I wanna do
crazy stuff so we're gonna go on top of
this go down and we're gonna jump on
some Forza
Sega and
in 2022 T3 2023 2020. uh I play like yes
I did play like a dragon
question is did you guys play like a
dragon
who in the chat has played like a dragon
right here is good enough
it's really like deep too
whoa
I do like these tricks man
oh I don't like these tricks oh my God
are you playing
are you allowed to play that on air play
what on air
I'm curious what you mean by play what
on air
you have to be a little bit more
specific man
what do you mean on air
Force yes forza's um embargo has been
lifted I can play it if I want to
technically I said I was gonna play
Wednesday well yesterday I don't know
did the reviews come out today
oh God
yeah let's go and jump on four so you
guys wanna you guys want a four as a
stream let's let's jump on Forza man uh
whenever ride Republic stuff pops up
like I do want to play more uh more of
it now look here's the deal
don't expect nothing from me in this
game
don't expect anything
I mean that all right I don't expect you
don't expect anything in me playing this
game effectively
you saw what was happening in writer's
Republic I was I was eating dirt don't
expect that here
like expect
the absolute worst
that's all I gotta say man expect the
absolute work
just to be on the safe side though guys
just to be on the safe side man let me
let me double check
the Embargo just to be on the safe side
now I'm not I'm pretty confident that
the that I'm allowed to stream this game
like I'm I'm 88 sure I'm allowed to
stream this game but that 12 chat that
12 we gotta double check we gotta double
check because
I'm not breaking embargo but I'm pretty
sure the Embargo is up
yes the Embargo is definitely up
it is definitely up chat so we good we
good
the Embargo is up
all right so what's going on in the chat
hold up this game looks dope uh I don't
know what game you were talking with D4
are you talking about writers Republic
we played that for about 45 minutes I
had to play that longer but the the this
thing that I was doing wasn't uh working
I think they're servers are having
issues
I don't know what that was about I'll
probably just do a review for that game
because I have played a good amount of
it
foreign
it looks like this is like a drag strip
actually you know what you guys know
what I want to do because
um
the access thing came up I want to go up
here and play a lot of this battle
royale because I didn't get to play a
whole lot of it during the beta uh
because you had like certain things that
you could do to play the beta
but now it should be opened up like
entirely for me hopefully
so I I'm reading the the chat a little
bit more thoroughly
um
if they did destiny-like raids I would
lose my [__] like I would really and
truly lose my [__] if there was Destiny
like raids and Halos but I don't know
how they would do that
yards
I'm very interested in how they would
achieve that see look at look at look
how crazy this car is it's everywhere
[Music]
here we go
driving pretty well man
oh I almost had that man I was almost
good
you guys think I should change the the
name the playing Forza Horizon 5 too
Halo needs raids make it happen imagine
if you fought like one of the Guardians
from Halo 5 in a wraith because those
Guardians can't be gone where where
could that go
thought you meant for the pull out the
window dear God lord yo that would be
crazy [__] if uh Forza had like a gun
system
oh my God I did yeah I I keep being
forgetting about the the setting stuff
I don't even know where to go for that
hold up
where is the settings I think it's at
like the end or something hold up we
gotta find the settings
there it is
uh I think it's an audio
the car
what is it home Cinema
horns
I thought that was a yeah streamer mode
on
there we go
we good now
we good
kinda
left so much different without the
copyrighted stuff
this car is everywhere I need a better
vehicle
[Music]
I'm kind of curious any Destiny fans in
the chat tell me how you think they
could pull off a raid in Halo
I want to like kind of know how they
would do that
guys gotta Enlighten you man how would
they do that what would be a good way
[Music]
oh God
I don't think there's nothing I could do
because that's like a long drive
we'll just have to hit it ain't nothing
I could do about it
you could tune the vehicle I don't know
how to tune anything
[Music]
I'm not really there for like anything
of the tuning and stuff but I know it's
a racing game so it would make sense
that I was able to do like the tuning
but that's just something that's never
really like resonated with me if that
makes sense to you guys
oh
you could tune the vehicle I know man
I need to slow down
I don't really have a like a very good
vehicle
you could auto tune now
well I think I'm about to get out of
this car anyway because I'm about to go
into this battle royale thing just make
sure I don't hit a big tree
if we want to search for a battle royale
[Music]
all right there we go
all right so it looks like
be cool if it was like a raid VR where
100 odsg drop in and got a work to beat
the final boss in the middle and collect
weapons upgrades from Outpost that would
be a unique way of doing a br but do you
guys like honestly feel like people
would want that from a br I feel like
you might upset people that be doing the
BR stuff they this is Eliminator they
really want me to use a
a beetle sorry
wow
we're getting dropped man we're getting
dropped
wonder how this uh this Mode's gonna go
man I wonder how it's going to treat us
Cortana lost the Vault of Glass
it'd be cool if uh Destiny uh Destiny
and Halo had like a little crossover
where it turns out that like Destiny's
in the Halo Universe but a couple years
in the future like a couple hundred
years in the future
so I don't know how this works so
there's 36 drivers left
I don't know exactly what we're doing
here
current car like are they supposed to
hit me or something
so you could change cars it looks like
area is shrinking oh God
oh
drink the
milk
inside the big Force Base
oh this is interesting
be nice to change so I could be hard to
something more team than PVP only maybe
for like a mo but I do feel like if you
make a PVP aspect it's got to have this
the core PV of a battle royale with
whatever mode is team oriented
they did their own little Battle Royale
I played a couple games of this but I
didn't play like a whole lot of it
oh Porsche
set up great clean car clean car
keep an eye out for more Flags oh
yeah yeah
look man
I can't help it
[Music]
so how do I eliminate
do I hit him
hold up
oh what's going on
I've done it now oh we got a race there
was Hunter about to whoop my ass
look how much faster he is than me
are you going off road we go off-road to
then
I ain't listening
oh God he's so much faster than me
wait
make this thing make this more fair
you don't gotta beat me so bad
I hope you hit a tree
something
around
oh God
I'm gonna try to stay on the downhill
climb
oh God
oh he about to beat me
I'm about to get eliminated
maybe I should have stayed on the road
and got a faster vehicle
oh God
this dude just went straight for for the
jugular
stock tracking
I need a better vehicle before I be
challenging people like a fool
because he went straight off the road
like he didn't even try
to do that stuff on the road
way up there man
did he go on the road yeah I'm about to
get eliminated
yeah
I got eliminated
got eliminated guys that's not fair
I feel like we need to do we need to
play that again
I don't know if I could do that again
I got eliminated and that wasn't fair
there's a limited edition
just have to keep playing then won't you
so there's another one started man so
you can you got it's the loot pickup
like a br game it seems like I hope he
hits a tree yeah I do I hope to hit a
tree but unfortunately it was me that
hit the tree he didn't hit the tree I
hit the tree
[Music]
it is different I honestly say it is
different now I got to get like imagine
if we got the whole Community to do this
that would be interesting we got the
whole Community to do a br of
this got like a bunch of streamers a
bunch of content creators get some
viewers in here
because that means 34 people
[Music]
look I will challenge people however I
want to
[Music]
you guys hear me I challenge whoever I
want to it don't matter
you know I'm still gonna lose that's
fine
that would be fun all right all right
all right let's let's be real here chat
let's be real we got the iron Lords
podcast RDX
name some other podcasts man it's
another podcast uh booms podcast
Randolph Thor Xbox 2 with jazz
we need more man we need more we need
more podcasts more podcasts uh look
hmm
gas is podcast and all of us
did a battle royale Forza stop who's
winning chat tell me who is winning
if anyone in the chat says me you're
losing automatically because I'm pretty
sure every one of them was Destroy me
game on daily
oh so so guys gonna beat me
pong Soul oh so see see I don't man game
on daily you guys be saying game on
daily is that nice and simple
[Music]
I gotta stay away from game on daily
season gaming
we gotta find a vehicle man we gotta
find a good vehicle hold up
all right so there's some smoke over
there I'm assuming that smoke leads to a
vehicle
because we need a vehicle
we can't be racing people naked like
this hold up there's that Porsche we'll
grab a Porsche until we get something
different
oh it's on top of uh it's on that bridge
hold up we gotta go around we gotta go
around
we gotta go around
hopefully it's still better by the time
we get there but we gotta go around
[Music]
that's unfortunate
can you even go around
I don't like this car I need something
different
I got to get up here man there we go
[Music]
we got to get another vehicle
there's a warthogging Forza yeah I
actually uh
I don't think I don't own it but I can
buy it I got a little bit of money on us
towards it you guys want me to buy the
the warthog and do some races with it
guys want me to get the warthog and do
some races with it we'll lose maybe
we'll get it in one of these drops
yeah
[Music]
that would be good if we got it one of
these jobs
[Music]
yeah I
um
look
Forza is it my type of game but it is
fun just to chill with the chat you know
do stuff that uh I like fun unique
experiences and I will say that Forza is
giving me a fun unique experience
oh God oh God
I'm hitting everything known to man
it's an issue with that
oh
dude that's fine I drive horrible and
I'm perfectly okay with that
[Music]
there's another
hold up there's another smoke up there
yeah I see Colton Diller I don't want
none of that smoke that coat and dealer
has I don't want none of that smoke
what is your guys's favorite BR out of
curiosity what's your favorite VR
favorite VR guys
gonna have to come clean man
good thing you get points for destroying
stuff
oh see now we talking
we got a Porsche man now we talking we
got something
that I that that I'm familiar with and
maybe not this older before it's just it
looks ancient but we got something man
someone said this
what's a VR look man VR
we good we good we are
I'm not the biggest fan of BR either but
I I do understand like how much it's
done
br's Battle Royale in case you really
did not I'm pretty sure you're probably
trolling but if you didn't know it's
Battle Royale
foreign
Apex Legends I actually wanted to jump
on and try some Apex Legends probably
not today in this stream because I'm
only streaming a writers Republican
Forza today I'll probably jump back on
writer's public after I do a little bit
more of this because I really want to
play that that mode and show you guys
that mode that Mode's like the funnest
thing about the game
and not to mention uh rise Republic
looks like it's got a little decent
little story though I'm going there
oh
we still good we still good
where is more smoke chat do you see more
smoke
we need more smoke
what is that
I need more smoke
we need
more smoke
[Music]
Fall Guys is a great battle royale
yeah added driving in Hood cam mode
look I'm just looking for smoke so I can
upgrade this more
yeah yeah that is like uh that is a br
a where
is the smoke
oh
hold up
I'm not trying to sin
anything
force is too good
I'll probably change the title after
after the uh the topic first off let's
go on to the second topic man I know we
got a little bit carried away into what
we're playing let's talk about
PlayStation PC cells I looked at the man
and they weren't looking as good as I
thought they would be I'ma be real with
you guys I thought they would sell more
than what they sold
um
I wonder how PlayStation feels about
those
it considering they're old games they're
probably so fun
what is this
looks like something better attic watch
out for the house if you build out of
nowhere
all right what
can I have my Porsche back
oh this thing
oh God
no stay away I need that smoke
I'm going to the ah
I'm going to the smoke
I'm gonna make it there I promise
[Music]
yeah it didn't sell as well as I thought
it would I will admit that like for some
reason with like PC games sell a couple
million that's like extremely successful
but I feel like a lot of people feel
like like Xbox needs to sell like 20
million units before it's successful
did someone take that smoke
where is that smoke
there's the smoke
towards the smoke
I'm going for that smoke man oh I see
someone going there
let me have this folk please you don't
take that smoke don't be that guy
don't be that guy man let me have that
smoke
don't be that guy
let me have it
all right so that's better oh it looks
like someone someone wants it all right
hold up
he's head for the center of the Arena
oh oh here we go
here we go chat
here we go
we gotta go left
oh that water slowed us down a little
bit chat but we good 1.7 miles
[Music]
faster than me
I feel like he's faster than me
oh I don't want to go into the forest
I don't want to go into the forest I
feel very uncomfortable in the forest
I'm about to get eliminated again man
I'm about to get eliminated again
I should have stayed away from this
Force
wow look how fast he's going
he's on he's in a car I think
it's not obviously hard I should have
stayed on the road I think that's what
he did I think he stayed on the road
hold up
we gotta jump we gotta go through it
guys
we gotta hope we get there [__]
I will not yep I got eliminated I got
eliminated man I got eliminated
I placed 20.
yeah some of the trees man some of the
trees a little rough some of the trees
will definitely mess you up
got a Hummer
yeah I might I think I'm gonna go back
to uh Rider's Republic and try that out
again
because there is some stuff I would like
to really show you guys like
but man it wasn't working the way it was
supposed to you did great until you hit
the forest I'm sure if you played more
and got used to the controls you would
like it more I actually enjoy Horizon
now look I don't know if I'm Gonna Keep
It on the hard drive
because it's so big
pause pause it's pause I gotta do a
pause
preactive pause
I think I need I need a um one of those
external
external storages I do think I need one
of those
what do you guys think Chad you think we
need an external storage
I think things would work a lot better
if we had one of those
just a little bit
oh my God
you guys oh here it is it's working now
it's working now
it's working
I love
the I love the tools they give you in
the free roam like see see how I'm like
flying up
then what you do man is like you go up
here
and just switch to the parachute
switch to the parachute guys we go
paragliding I think that's what it's
called it might not be what it's called
oh
here we go
let's get as close to the ground as
possible
close to the ground as possible
oh
hold up hold up watch this
oh so that won't work
hold up
oh no hold up we got it we got us get
this
you know I actually want to go somewhere
higher it's called a wing suit oh it's
called a wing suit I didn't know what it
was called man I didn't know what it was
called
all right so let's go here
all right so now what I like doing
with this wings
oh
all right so let's get a little bit
closer to the ground
wait for it
foreign
we didn't see that you guys didn't see
that that didn't happen
I'm an expert all right
I'm an expert
you guys know how it is
isn't that an accident
that hurts my soul when he gets hit like
that
oh hold on let's go back to the little
air thing
let's show you guys how the wing suit
works
yeah I like taking this one right here
you're an extra
what is that supposed to mean Splendid
you don't have to be a little bit more
specific what you mean by I'm an extra
I don't like that that
energy you throwing out in the world
saying that I'm an extra
that's rude
Mercy in people what you mean on mercy
of people
all right here we go
you're supposed to get points the closer
you get
yeah see see you get points now chat
what we got to do is we can't hit
nothing
and then we gotta hit something
then we got hit again
there's like a really good place on the
map where there's like water and stuff
beside it
yeah let's do it like right here I think
this is a good place
yeah like right here is good
there we go
see how long we can keep it going guys
I got this
I could do this for a minute
here we go
stop putting that negativity in the chat
I feel it
I don't have to wreck
oh God
here we go so far I got a good little
good little thing going hold up
there's an under engine that looks just
like this that's interesting
another fun thing that you can do is
just come through with the uh
get like a trick bike like a trick uh
ski thing I don't like how you can't
snowboard on here I think it would be
cool if you could snowboard
I used to really enjoy like the the 1080
Avalanche you guys remember the 10 uh at
1080 on uh on like the I think it was
the n64.
I don't know if you guys remember that
1080 Avalanche or something like that it
was called something like that
can I change the
field of view
well I can turn the motion blur off
that's for sure
doesn't look like there's a field of
view option unfortunately
doesn't look like it man
Oh I thought I was going to make that
for a second
this game seems different to me like
this is just the free roam uh next like
they actually have like a story and
stuff too I played a little bit of the
story I like just like doing the free
roam stuff I don't know why it's like
soothing to me
thank you
like they give you like this big
best singer fov is PC exclusive death
you know that there's more places that
do that than just PC stop with the the
nonsense
vertical takeoff
you know Dad
's in here trying to start some stuff
stop that nonsense stuff
then what we're going to do
is switch
oh God oh God
oh
switch
the behind the shoulders bother me do
you like rather it been like first
person
I'm kind of curious on that dude you
rather have been first person
this guy's gonna have to be honest with
me about that man
first person is that what's going on
here
look at that we taking a little a little
stroll in the water
look man
I thought I had a good chance I didn't
realize I didn't
yeah but that's why I really enjoy it
like you know
Drive
I I enjoyed it plus you know Ubisoft
hooked hooked you hooked addict up man
they they gave me the uh review code and
I really enjoyed what I've played of it
like the the sad part about it is like I
do think it came out like a weird time
that I think they needed to be a little
bit more like strategic in the the
releasing window like because I feel
like there's a lot of stuff going on so
you know and it's a fun little game and
that I I feel like they they kind of
messed up a little bit where they
actually launched the game
they need to do a little bit better on
future games like because this isn't
like a Von hauler or something
uh this is writer's Republic
yeah that's what I'm saying like
do a better release date like release
date for some reason this many years
have went by and I feel like Publishers
still don't understand that their game
can die with a bad release date
yes
see look how long I've been in these
Snowy Mountains like the the map's huge
I feel like this is like their spiritual
successor to steep
I don't know if it's made by the same
company but
oh I didn't wreck that's good
that time I wrecked
water skiing again for the win
water skiing man
but I know that that looks boring
what guys would you guys like to see me
stream like
I think I might do one of these once a
week do you guys think it would be cool
to do one of these once a week
just talk about you know chatting it up
man maybe like get get an IOP thing
going sometime so what when one of the
Lords is free get like king or someone
in here
them trees again I'm staying away from
the trees
staying away from the trees I don't
trust those trees
oh God
okay so it's getting a little bit slow
so I think what we're gonna do is we're
gonna switch
I mean I'll I'll think about it I'm not
promising anything but I'll think about
it
because I already do a lot a week adding
a stream you know we'll have to see
I don't know about twice a week right
you're getting a little ridiculous man
you know you get a little ridiculous
I don't think I'll be playing uh
Fantasy Star I think I'm gonna stay away
from Fantasy Star I
oh here we go
yeah I this is a bad idea this is really
bad idea
this is a really bad idea
yeah
we're not we're not doing that
we we are surviving we're not hitting
the ground
that was that was that was a nightmare
it's a Nightmare Man
they could have did a little bit better
than that
oh
nose diving look man
we will get through whatever we can
because that's what we do
we'll get to whatever we can so so death
you want to jump in in an Xbox Live
party give you a little opinion on uh on
the PlayStation PC cells you want to
jump in a Discord or something a Discord
something I would prefer Xbox Live
because I'm already in Xbox Live but
that's just my opinion
foreign
let me try to think of like the best way
to do this because I feel like Discord
like
I feel like Discord would be the most
efficient way of doing it
yeah let me just sit send me an in oh
it's a damn bear oh my God her bear
we gonna We Gotta mess with the bear
where'd the bear go
there was a bear here I promised you
chat there was a bear here
I wasn't seeing nothing I don't do drugs
I promise I don't there was a bear here
foreign
there was a bear here
I'm confident there is a bear here
so you know
we're just gonna assume like the bear
was here
almost crashing I I I don't know what
happened there man that bear just
disappeared
I had a thin air
death singer
I sent dust singer an invite we're
listening to
when
he I sent you an invite death
there is there he goes let me change my
settings
he
he was on the other side of the river
give me once I have to change my
settings so they can hear you
can you hear me uh death
can you hear me
death oh
yeah only on the stream no I can I can
hear you
can you not hear me oh oh wait wait I'm
an idiot all right can you hear me now
yeah I can hear you now yeah okay yeah
that that was my fault that was my fault
so what's going on death how do you feel
about the PC thing man how you feel
about the pieces
number one
the sales
I mean are they sales they would not
have got and they eat that was a
four-year-old game like
imagine if that game was only a year old
how much
that bear disappeared again
that bear I I
I ain't gonna even try the best Bears
anymore okay continue continue
well which part of the PC's um
PlayStation do you want to talk about
all of it some of it just the sales
yeah we'll talk about the cells do you
think that
for the the amount of cells they got is
worth what uh like you know taking the
exclusivity part do you think that's
worth it
yeah definitely because if you sold the
rate of the return on investment when
they released it from Verizon
we know how much they saw up there and
that was like 270 that he made handle
fit
something could be basically the cost of
nothing and they just made what a
million
some sales just for nothing so
the sales number is good and bear in
mind wait till God of God of War is
gonna do more numbers on these time
is going to do more than all of them
combined
exaggeration I reckon God of War will do
it
really a lot
putting stuff on PC is 2 million really
a lot
considering the game is released in 2018
that's pretty good for an old game
what's up Nightcrawler's podcast
well what what you want from like a
four-year-old game you know it's not
that I think that it's a fort give me a
second guys I'm gonna go get something
to drink real quick
I can still hear you death
a dude's getting thirsty you have to
apologize man I have to apologize
let's put that over there I'll throw
that way later
dude's getting thirsty man he's getting
thirsty so like okay I understand where
you're coming from I still disagree I
don't think that that those kind of
cells
but you don't think you'll do two
million
despite their strand into a 1.5
how long has this Australian been on are
you talking about the whole life cells
yeah yeah remember to put it the numbers
yeah I could see that all right I could
see that
because if they're striving to do 1.5
given a bit of time gotta walk
too good
God of War is bigger than that stranded
like to me it's just a matter of time
before they do day and day like that's
just my opinion oh that's coming you
need to start fooling yourself
day and day is coming guys it's coming
you care about making money
and Ryan is a money man
friend
he's not really even a gamer probably
this guy
no I think it's just a he is just the
money man he's the guy if you need to
make money so
so he's gonna make some money
and board of directors will be
incredibly happy
promotion and everything you don't think
at the end of the day that that's like
not an issue
no and it's not gonna hit console sales
because
they are two fundamentally different
people they were PC guys that will never
touch a console there are console guys
who will never touch a PC that is a fact
and
those two fan bases will never converge
there'll be some in the middle we'll go
half and half
but
as Matt piss guitar pointed out in like
one third of the PC players in an online
thing on the PS4 still search don't care
they don't own a console
so to them it's like whatever
just money
I get it I do good
to me though like I do feel like
there is to a point where like they are
losing some of their Branch like not
necessarily their brand but they're
losing some of the like
the importance of having a PlayStation
and I don't feel like like the numbers
is uh is worth that loss of importance
of having a console but you know maybe
you know when we start seeing closer
today I think that's the biggest issue
no one wants to buy a game where they
already know the ending a lot of people
have like our work came out years ago
2018. so they're they're seeing a lot of
this a lot of that game already spoiled
conversation is
it really doesn't hold much water
because
like people will still buy PlayStation
because PlayStation is the most popular
and biggest gaming brand
like that that is not going to change
the releasing games let's say you don't
sell five billion more consoles
okay
but those five million consoles
you don't really make money off them you
just make money off the games so why not
just sell the games and sacrifice five
million consoles
so it only hurts fanboys
it doesn't actually hurt
you know
the actual fun thing I get what you're
saying so let me ask the uh the chat I'm
pretty sure you got they can hear you
right can you hear yourself in the in
the Stream all right that'd be four of
what they can't hear
me this whole time they're talking and
they can't hear you man well I can't
really say like talk real quick yep yep
yeah yeah they can hear me
all right man all right so so so I I
have went to the full cam you know I
went back over to the full cam
so according
to
death singer he doesn't think it's
really going to hurt them much I don't
know I'm a little bit in the middle when
it comes to it uh I do think that in
some form they are losing some of their
branding by putting games day and date
in something but I I understand you know
where they're coming from
by wanting that money because uh there's
probably more people on the PC platform
that would buy that game than there is
that wouldn't buy it
hmm
I I'm pretty sure that's what you're
saying right
well I'm gonna say for now it costs 250.
you are only selling the maximum 20
million
so how are you gonna make up the money
you're losing
PC
oh stop addict they're saying I'm being
toxic right now death
I'm being toxic toxic
I don't know I don't feel this This
Witch Hunt for my toxicity man I told
you at the beginning of the podcast try
to do better
try it I don't need this
too much toxicity making a thumbnail for
the for for this video guys I'm making
it I'm trying don't don't do this to me
guys don't do this to me
let me uh
hold up
they want I kinda
hold up guys
guys want to see how uh I go about
making my thumbnails
see that this is uh this is paint.net I
know I don't use the one that everyone
uses you guys are gonna have to get over
that I apologize but it's it's my life
and I can make things however I want now
this is how I think I'm gonna make it uh
I'm going to
let's see let's let's see what I want to
do here man see what I want to do here
you guys gonna witness me live make this
this man you gotta witness me live make
it so first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
pop in my emblem because that's just my
emblem and I have every right to use it
anywhere I want to so that there's my
emblem
look at that sexy beast man there's my
as you guys could see we're going to
start with the emblem all right behind
the scenes there you go behind the
scenes I should make this as a members
only thing no I'm joking I wouldn't do
that to you guys I wouldn't do that to
you guys all right so here here's uh
here's my emblem now what we're gonna do
is uh because we play two games deer in
this stream two
we play a little bit of uh
Rider's Republic
played some writers Republic let's find
a good
something good to use variety of
Republic with I think we're gonna go
with this
we want this to be on top so we're going
to put this here
drag this up we want this like right
there man I think that's good then what
did we play next we played some Forza
so we gotta look for four is a good
picture for Forza because that's what we
do
Forza Horizon 5.
uh we don't need
the thing showing it we just need the uh
we need to make another layer because we
want this to be on like right here
then what we're going to do is we're
going to use a tool that I was taught
how to use
shout out to Anchorman
uh where is it gradient
we're gonna make it like right here
bam
see then we're gonna fuse these two like
a gauntlet
and we're going to give it a slight
unfocused just a little bit
to make just to make my Logo Pop out
just a little bit
then what we're going to do
is just shrink this just a little bit
there we go
and I think that's the thumbnail guys
it's done we made the thumbnail I made
it live and I made it really fast too
ah
see I'm drinking some propels what kind
of what kind of drinks do you guys drink
over there across the sea Beth
foreign
what drinks do you drink I didn't ask
what's popular I said what does what
does death dream
oh so you drink juice you a juice
drinker
oh hold up hold up they can't hear you
so let me go back to uh
we go back to the stream and one man
guys I I apologize man they they
couldn't hear me when I was doing my
thumbnail but uh they can hear you now
oh man there we go all right
so 100 apple juice none of that
sweetened
um extra apple juice just straight up
pure apple juice and I drink water I
don't drink any pop
I don't drink any alcohol
um so you don't yeah I pretty much just
water water and juice yeah just water
and juice Street yeah I wish I was that
strong won't you hand me some of that
strength over here man
amen I've been to a young age whereas I
stopped drinking when I was 24 24 yeah
and then I because I woke up one day
funny story I woke up after you know a
late night party
I realized I spent 200 right and then I
sat there I was like I spent 200 of my
money that I earned I'm going to work
and I make myself feel like crap why am
I paying someone to make me feel bad and
I stopped I was like what am I doing you
got a point there man you do got a point
there
yeah nice doesn't make sense
you know Chad why do we uh we engage
ourselves in stuff that uh is just gonna
mess us up more
it's a good point we should probably
stop doing that
stop doing that we we should
pop pop just got more expensive like
like so so now we now we know what's
going on all right all right
so so
pop just got more expensive
it's like being my friend like
like because I know most people are
Americans buying the same liters anyway
because that's the measurements we use
five liters
five liters of water a day
well I drink five liters of water but
that's yep that's really good actually
I'm all about people being healthy man
I'm trying my hardest to do better with
it I'm trying my hardest
we're probably about the in the Stream
here soon I I'm redoing everything
uh
writers rep ublik
he said beers for me only
I gave up that life like seven years ago
[Music]
all right so let me uh once I finish
this we're gonna call it a stream you
know so before we call it a stream
though tell me in the chat what you guys
would like to see
me stream I'm curious to hear that
what would you guys like to see mystery
what would be interesting
and don't say some dumb stuff like
don't say some old games
Animal Crossing look at that alrighty
with some uh
with some old games
I don't know how I feel about that you
guys don't need to be so extra with that
man
guys don't need to be so extra play
Forza Horizon five I think I'm down for
for the day man uh I got I got to do
some business stuff here in a minute
um
you know
I think I might play more Forza when I
get some friends you got fours of death
you got Forza
are you waiting for that game pass
death
talking to you death
you know uh yeah I have it I
I didn't want to shout out for the
extras so I'm kind of wait until the
ninth but it works out because I have to
do finish some stuff up on Final Fantasy
14 so far we might play some Final
Fantasy 14 man oh really keep in mind
that I play
all the streams on the gaming addict
Channel and I played on the IOP twitch I
don't really stream a whole lot of stuff
on here
um but writers Republican Forza Horizon
5 uh they gave us access to these games
early and I wanted to show you know the
chat that both of these games are really
fun now um Forza Forza is different
beasts Man force is a different beast
and Riders Republic you know the story
is pretty solid uh I like that free roam
that free roam's fun but you got you
know I'm a little in the Stream here you
guys I'm tired and uh I I need I need
some time to
to to really
what's the world I'm looking for I need
some time to
to consume
and and re-generate like what today's
Friday the podcast is in two days so
definitely uh testing for the iron Lords
podcast
on um
on Sunday at 11 A.M but until next time
you guys this is Gaby addict I'm